Just one half of a teaspoon of this one
thing can be comparable to ibuprofen for
inflammation. And that thing is
turmeric. I'm not talking about the
turmeric that you sprinkle on your food
or your eggs. I'm talking more about a
concentrated turmeric because turmeric
is a spice, but there's a certain thing
in turmeric called curcumin that is
really doing the magic. But you can't
just take turmeric as a spice and expect
it to do what I'm going to show you
right now. So many videos complicate
this topic with all these big
biochemical names. All you need to know
is this very simple. There are four
master switches or dials that will turn
up pain and inflammation or turn down
pain and inflammation. And that's
basically the gist of it. This dial
right here is the pain and inflammatory
factory. It produces pain signals and
inflammation. The second dial is the
master inflammation on switch. So it'll
trigger hundreds of different genes in
relationship to turning on inflammation.
It's kind of like the master circuit
breaker for inflammation. And then you
get the third dial. This is the
inflammation megaphone. It's like an
amplifier. It amplifies inflammation. It
doesn't cause pain directly. It just
keeps inflammation going on and on and
on. And this is why a lot of the drugs
for autoimmune diseases target this
biochemical pathway. And then we have
the fourth alarm right here. This is the
backup inflammatory alarm system that
keeps screaming long after the fire is
over. And I'm talking about
inflammation. And this is why certain
treatments will address one thing, but
they don't address everything
necessarily. And this one's really
important for asthma, inflammation, and
autoimmune disease. So, now you know the
basics on biochemistry as far as pain
and inflammation. Let's first talk about
ibuprofen. Ibuprofen is really good at
turning this knob off. Pain and
inflammation, and it does so very
quickly. But here's the problem. Part of
this process here protects certain
organs like your stomach and like your
kidneys. And so when you take ibuprofen,
it will turn off those pathways and you
can end up getting side effects like
stomach ulcers, problems with the
kidneys, aka side effects. And the other
thing you need to know about ibuprofen,
ibuprofen does not deal with these other
pathways. It doesn't deal with the
master inflammatory on switch or the
megaphone or the backup inflammatory
system. And this is why people have to
keep taking it over and over and over
again because it doesn't resolve the
whole process. Now, just as a side note,
Tylenol doesn't even affect any one of
these. Tylenol works in your brain and
so it shuts off the central nervous
system for pain so you don't feel it,
but it doesn't do anything for
inflammation. What about aspirin?
Aspirin only focuses on this pathway
right here. Not this one, not this one,
or this one right here. But as you know,
when you block things right here, you
can create side effects with the
stomach. This is why people that take
aspirin end up having bleeding stomach
sometimes and other side effects. Now,
with Tylenol, you can have a lot of side
effects in your liver. Now, let's switch
over to turmeric. What does turmeric do?
Turmeric has a completely different
strategy. It affects not just the COX
pathway, but this pathway and this
pathway right here. not as strong, but
it starts to turn down the dial of all
three of these right here. And the
research, which I'm going to share in a
minute, involves taking 1500 mg with
black pepper because black pepper helps
the absorption of turmeric. But only a
half a teaspoon of this extract can
create a comparable effect to ibuprofen.
Let me just tell you a little bit about
this study. This study was a randomized
controlled study. It was double blind.
It was on a reasonable sample size, 367
people, and it was peer-reviewed and
published on humans, not mice. And it
showed that concentrated turmeric per
cumin at 1,500 milligrams with black
pepper showed comparable effects to
ibuprofen. But the biggest thing that I
think you need to know is without the
side effects that you would get with
ibuprofen. There's a couple other things
that I want to share with you. Extra
virgin olive oil does mimic some of the
effects of ibuprofen at the molecular
level. Not as strong as ibuprofen, but
it turns down the dial. And so this is
why I would recommend using this on a
regular basis on your salad. And as a
fun fact, do you know that little tingle
that you get in the back of the throat
when you actually consume the real
extravirgin olive oil? Did you realize
that if you took liquid ibuprofen, you
would get the same effect on your
throat? Couple other things. Ginger is
kind of an unrecognized, undernowledged
remedy for this pathway right here,
which is really good for turning down
inflammation. This pathway is like the
amplifier of inflammation. Also, this
pathway is where the omega-3 fatty acid
works. Like fish oil, cad oil will
address this pathway, which helps reduce
inflammation. Now, hum addresses this
one right here. A lot of people take
this for autoimmune disease. And now you
know why? Because it reduces the
megaphone of inflammation. But it does
not work on this pathway, this pathway,
or even this pathway. Let's talk about
this pathway. It's called five locks.
This is the backup inflammatory alarm
system. This is the one that can still
activate even by shutting these off
right here. It just so happens that
bosellia, which is an herb, this targets
five locks. So, Boswellia is another
great remedy for inflammation. And now
you know where it fits into the scheme
of things. Now, I want to answer a
bigger question. We've talked about what
turns off pain signals, but my question
is, what turned them on in the first
place? What is the root cause of all of
these right here? All right, I have my
other whiteboard here. There's actually
five primary things that turn on the
inflammatory switches. Okay, and this is
actually more important than the last
part because if you know what turns it
on, then you can actually not just
manage the pain and inflammation, you
can correct it. And this is the part
that medicine doesn't focus on. All of
the ones I'm going to talk about turn on
all four of those pathways. And if we
can correct these, we can not only turn
all of them off, but we can actually
make sure they don't come back. The
biggest one is insulin resistance.
Insulin resistance happens when you
consume a lot of carbohydrates over a
long period of time, sugar and starch,
and also you eat frequently. So you're
snacking on a lot of things. And also
you can get this from consuming too many
seed oils. People with insulin
resistance have a lot of pain and
inflammation. Okay. Number two,
mitochondrial damage can come from a lot
of things. It could come from this. It
could come from smoking. It could come
from junk foods, ultrarocessed foods. It
can come from overtraining, not getting
enough sleep, having a sedentary
lifestyle. And then number three, we
have chronic oxidative stress. This
could be from a lot of things. Toxicity,
it could be from smoking, drinking,
eating junk foods. And number four,
leaky gut. Again, this relates to things
that you are eating. Ultrarocessed
foods. Gluten can do it and ced can
create leaky gut. And then number five,
you have chronic infections like you
could have Lyme disease. You could also
have Epstein bar virus or herpes virus
that can go in and out of remission. But
what's interesting about that, people
with chronic stress can activate these
latent viruses that can come out of
remission and create inflammation. But
what's interesting is these are the five
things that turn on these switches. And
so if we're going to use medication to
turn those off and get side effects and
ignore these, then we're really missing
the boat. So if we look at these, we
want to correct them with going on a low
carb diet, okay? Because that's how you
correct insulin resistance. You have to
give up something called ultrarocessed
foods, aka junk foods. You want to do,
of course, intermittent fasting. Very
important. Intermittent fasting is
probably one of the most powerful things
to reduce inflammation that you can do.
Your inflammation just goes away. Your
arthritis goes away. And then prolong
fasting is the next level
anti-inflammatory because I've had
people with the most severe autoimmune
inflammatory conditions completely get
rid of inflammation by doing prolonged
fasting. There's several nutrients
involved in inflammation as well. Having
enough magnesium can reduce not just
inflammation, but any type of muscle
inflammation. And vitamin D is one of
the most powerful anti-inflammatories as
far as natural things as well. When
you're deficient in vitamin D, you're
going to have inflammation. If you're
lacking zinc, that can create
inflammation. If you don't have enough
omega-3 fatty acids, you can have
inflammation, especially if you have too
many omega-6 fatty acids, which is part
of the seed oils.